this episode was made possible by Wix
build your own professional website with
Wix by following the link below the
pre-revolution years were full of
tension and turmoil in the colonies that
would become the United States of
America take for example one of the most
inflammatory events of the time one that
helps set the stage for the American
Revolution the Boston Massacre before we
get to the actual event let's set the
stage with a little historical
background the year was 1776 of British
regulars had been stationed in Boston to
restore respect for British law many of
the locals hated the British soldiers
townspeople were upset because the
British would often accept part-time
work for lower pay which Bostonians saw
as stealing their jobs local sailors saw
British occupation as a constant threat
of impressment the law which authorized
colonists to be pressed into service in
the British Navy in the frozen early
months of 1770 escalations between
Bostonians and the soldiers were on the
rise on March 2nd a fist fight broke out
between British soldiers and locals
after one man asked a soldier if he was
looking for work when the soldier
responded that he was he was told to go
clean the man's outhouse in less
pleasant terms three days later on the
evening of March 5th trouble began
brewing all over the city
as with many conflicts it began with a
simple dispute this time between a wig
makers apprentice named Edward Garrick
and Captain John Goldfinch a passing
soldier Garrick insulted Goldfinch as he
walked by the store claiming that the
captain had not paid what he owed for a
new wig Goldfinch ignored the apprentice
but a nearby sentry named Hugh white
took offence walked over and after a
brief and heated argument struck Garrick
with his musket and knocked him down the
confrontation had drawn a crowd which
became furious after white assaulted the
young man the crowd grew to about 50
people many of whom began throwing
chunks of ice at the soldier and
threatening him with derogatory names
white fled to the local custom house
loaded his gun and pleaded for the
soldiers inside to come to fend him not
far from the scene a second mob had
assembled and began pelting a group of
soldiers with ice and snowballs forcing
them to retreat into their barracks
meanwhile a third more dangerous mob
nearly 200 strong and carrying clubs had
formed in doc square they rang the fire
bells to draw more civilians into the
streets and began to march towards the
Custom House the officer of the day
Captain Thomas Preston was in a
difficult spot if he didn't organize his
troops
the mob might kill Hugh white but
sending out more men would put them all
in trouble and potentially escalate the
situation even further after almost half
an hour of thinking Preston decided the
only thing to do was rescue white the
captain and seven other men marched out
forced their way through the crowd and
stood by the terrified soldier now they
were stuck the mob which had grown to
over 300 was pressing in and throwing
ice chunks of coal
hoist er shells anything they could get
their hands on one man named Crispus
Attucks grabbed a soldier's bayonet and
knocked him to the ground as the man got
back to his feet he yelled at the other
soldiers to fire even though he had no
authority and thus began what became
known as the Boston Massacre Crispus
Attucks was shot twice in the chest
another man was quoted to have been shot
in the head as he stood with his hands
in his pockets leaving a hole the size
of a man's hand all told five civilians
were killed and another half dozen
injured before captain Preston by his
own account was able to get his men
under control to make a long story short
Preston and his men were arrested and
held for trial
over the next seven months various
accounts of the event began to pop up in
newspapers across the colonies and
especially in London each one skewing
the facts to present an argument against
the other side the Bostonians wanted the
British soldiers out and somewhat
surprisingly though after considerable
public pressure the British agreed the
morning after the soldiers were arrested
a local visited future President John
Adams then a Boston Attorney and begged
him to represent the soldiers at their
trials despite the considerable risks to
his reputation and his career Adams
agreed as he felt that every person
deserved a defense the trial would be
interesting for a number of reasons
first it was an intensely politically
charged event notable figures such as
Samuel Adams and John Hancock were
thoroughly opposed to British occupation
and the incident undoubtedly led to more
extreme ideas second it was the first
recorded use of the dying declaration
exception to the rule that excludes
hearsay evidence one of the victims of
the shooting
Patrick Carr lived for a short time
after the incident and told his surgeon
that he forgave whoever it was that shot
him and that the British had acted in
self-defense
in the end despite much anger and heated
debate outside the courthouse the
soldiers were all acquitted of murder
and only two of them were punished by
branding Adams his closing statement was
brief and poignant and it's worth
repeating here he said facts are
stubborn things and whatever may be our
wishes our inclinations or the dictates
of our passions they cannot alter the
state of facts and evidence
nor is the law less stable than the fact
if an assault was made to endanger their
lives the law is clear they had a right
to kill in their own defense if it was
not so severe as to endanger their lives
yet if they were assaulted at all struck
and abused by blows of any sort by
snowball's oyster shells cinders clubs
or sticks of any kind this was a
provocation for which the law reduces
the offense of killing down to
manslaughter in consideration of those
passions in our nature which cannot be
eradicated to your candor and justice I
submit the prisoners and their cause
despite the tragedy and despite the
nearly universal hatred of British
occupation in Boston John Adams stuck to
the principles that all of us should
strive to hold a respect for objective
evidence the law and rational thought
the legacy of the Boston Massacre has
been controversial even down to the name
was it really a massacre if the mob
incited the violence then again was
shooting into the crowd really the only
option the incident raises important
questions even today nearly two and a
half centuries later America was founded
on the right to peaceful assembly and
while the crowd in Boston was certainly
not peaceful at what point does it
become acceptable to shoot civilians
self-defence is a valid argument and
will generally hold up in most modern
court cases but should there be more
repercussions for the use of deadly
force especially by those who have
access to more lethal weapons like the
police and the military from the
civilian standpoint it would appear that
the only way to affect change is to
resort to violence and the civil unrest
that sparked the American Revolution
would seem to support that idea what
does that say about modern protests our
peaceful assembly is still effective
order those calling for more drastic
actions have the right idea what would
happen if police killed a handful of
protesters in 2018 would the legal
outcome be the same even with the
drastically lopsided difference in
firepower we can often gain key insights
into how society will respond to certain
events by looking to the Past and seeing
how our forefathers reacted in today's
polarized and volatile social landscape
a bit of historical perspective might be
a good thing what do you think is
violence against protesters ever
justified or on the other side is
violence against law enforcement ever
justified was John Adams right in
defending the soldiers who killed those
five people what do you think would
happen if there were a second Boston
Massacre today let us know your thoughts
in the comments below and if you really
have a lot to say about the issue why
not compile all your thoughts on a
beautiful new website from Wix with Wix
you can build amazing
professional websites for just about any
application Wix can handle any project
you throw at it whether you want to host
videos share your photo gallery book
clients sell products or just about
anything else you could ever want
whether you need a professional website
for your own personal use or for
e-commerce music hotels or restaurants
Wix does all the heavy lifting like
hosting custom domains email marketing
and more allowing you to focus on the
creative side of things you have total
creative freedom over your websites
allowing for limitless possibilities and
you don't even have to be a web designer
Wix caters to everyone regardless of
skill level so whether you're a novice
business owner or seasoned website
builder if you want to build your very
own professional website visit Wix by
following the link below